let's go next to jamie from las vegas
nevada
uh place with uh up until recently
extraordinarily high uh case positivity
jamie what's going on there
didn't get king henry
yes i can
awesome yeah so um me and my wife we did
get vaccinated
um
and i know if i do know if someone that
did not get vaccinated and they did
they did get the virus
yeah which is pretty devastating but you
know
anti-mass and anti-vaccines kind of will
put you there i guess
how sick did they get
yeah
so i just have a quick question really
um all right how do you really think
2024 will turn out
at the presidential level yes
i think it's too early to know uh so
much of it depends on what happens in
2022 and sort of the very brief outline
is if the people trump supports in 22
all do well and republicans take the
house there's a much better shot trump
runs and does well and maybe even is
unopposed in the republican primary if
the people trump supports lose or a
bunch of them do i think it'll really
weaken trump it'll diminish his power
within the party and you'll probably
start to see in 22 and 23 in 23 and the
early part of 24 uh republicans maybe
move away from trump and go in a
different direction so i think we just
don't have all the information yet that
we need in order to predict that
totally understandable and i think it'd
be shocking if uh trump would would even
be elected to get another term
i hope you're right but i fear that he
could i fear that he could because uh
his followers have shown that
reality and facts just don't affect them
and so i worry that he could get
reelected
absolutely and do you do you ever i
don't know if you have ever done this in
the past but would you ever consider
like um
kind of going into more of like what the
meaning is of socialism like kind of you
know
going over that yes we so we we've we've
done one long form video sort of about
that we have another one that's been
scripted up and we're going to be
recording it really really soon it's
going to be about exactly that so we
have a big video probably a 15 20 minute
video forthcoming on that yeah i just
know that you know fox news and newsmax
they totally
you know use that word and i don't think
they of course
they have no or at least they pretend
not to
oh yeah true for their their fan base
for their audience yeah exactly exactly
thank you for your time
all right appreciate it jamie from las
vegas great to hear from you a lot of
strong very very strong calls today